it started when it was just me and the
cameraman and a little and the Clockwork
camera you don't make Natural History
films like that anymore
the Natural History films now of this
sort of quality are made by literally
hundreds of people there may be thirty
there may be 50 cameraman who'll be
working on one particular program I
think something like 300 cameraman have
worked on the series as a whole because
now you've got the facilities to go up
in the skies and the bottom of the seas
you've got you could Trek over the over
the polar wastes you can go over the
deserts you can be in jungles of the
world and all those pictures you can
bring back in order to give a unique
picture which human beings haven't seen
until this generation one of the most
immediate dangers that are facing the
planet today is of course rising
temperatures and where you may see that
of course is actually more up in the
north than it is in the south but in the
Arctic the Arctic is temperatures rising
very very fast and how we that the team
who made this series determined of
course that they were needed pictures of
the melting ice that would symbolize
this and they went up to the north
now the glaciers in the end in up in the
north and the Arctic are moving very
fast indeed
and they went to one particular glass
here knowing that it was advancing into
the sea how the past but you need
gaseous always on the move a bit but you
need dramatic scene event they'll be
like children David unpredictable yes
it's though but they wanted to see the
gasser that was carving that say coming
off in lumps and they decided that the
way they would see that best would be
from the air and in a helicopter
they eventually and the very last day of
their of their location they were up in
the helicopter and they spied the glassy
are suddenly beginning to carve that
there were sections of the ratio the
size of a skyscraper of a great
magis storey building falling into the
water causing huge surges no you're a
helicopter pilot is that tricky it can
be David yes I mean huge up rushes
severe when the fast blocks fall into
the sea and and what that does and there
if you're a pilot
I mean you will know how you're going to
get a steady shot to see that the pilot
who was working on that helicopter has
my man nation and you would know much
much better than me how skilled he was
to get the sort of shots of the carving
at the Garcia which is included in this
series all helicopter pilots are very
skillful David for many years though as
a TV presenter at least you held back a
bit from speaking quite publicly about
its environmental issues ISM was that
reason you decided to do that um well
when I I started 60 years ago in Midland
mid the mid fifties and to be truthful I
don't think there was anybody in the in
the mid fifties who thought that there
was a danger that we might uh naya late
part of the natural world there are
animals that were in danger that's true
and there were animals that we could
seen if we didn't do something they were
going to become extinct and the notion
that human beings might exterminate a
whole species once uh slightly I would
say a llama one who just hadn't thought
about it and if it did occur
as it did with the Arabian oryx for
example it seemed the exception now of
course and we are only too well aware
that the whole of the natural world is
at our disposal as it were that we we we
can do things accidentally that
exterminate the whole area of the
natural world and the species that live
within it it's difficult to overstate it
we are now so numerous so powerful so
all pervasive the mechanisms that we
have for destruction are so wholesale
and so frightening that we can actually
just exterminate whole ecosystems
without even noticing it we have now to
be really aware of the dangers of what
we're doing and we already know that of
course of the plastic problem in the
seas is is wreaking appalling damage
upon marine life the extent of which we
don't yet fully know and why do you
think the sort of the world leaders and
those in in key positions of leadership
why do you think they've taken so long
and they've been quite a few faltering
steps to acts on environmental
challenges because the connection
between the natural world and the urban
world the Society of human society has
always since the industrial revolution
has been remote and widening and we
didn't realize the effects of what we
were doing out there but now we are
seeing that almost everything we do has
its echoes and has its duplications and
Inter implications across the natural
world so that we have now really to care
for what we do because we can
exterminate things without even knowing
the chain is so delicate isn't it and
that if you pluck out some of these gaps
without realizing what you're doing the
consequences the repercussions go for
generations yes
and talking of generations people of my
generation now beginning to step it up
positions of leadership around the world
the work to save the planet is probably
largely going to happen on our watch
what advice do you have for my
generation and what what can we build on
that you have started
I think the paradox that there has never
been more a time when more people have
been out of touch with the natural world
then as now and we have to recognize
that every breath of air we take every
mouthful of food that we take comes from
the natural world and that if we damage
the natural world we damage ourselves we
are one coherent ecosystem it's not just
a question of beauty or interest or
wonder it's the essential ingredient the
central part of human life is a healthy
planet we are in the danger of wrecking
that if we don't recognize those sort of
connections that I've been describing
then the whole of the planet comes in
hazard and we are destroying the natural
world and with it ourselves
David it just remains me to say a huge
thank you on behalf of everyone here for
you being here today it's talk I'm sorry
openly and a huge congratulations again
for winning the crystal ward a round
applause please visit a raffle bro